and let's uh start with a quick review
of uh last lecture so last time uh we
talked about lasers we learned about
lasers specifically uh well the lazing
principle and then specifically we
looked at solid uh semiconductor laser
diodes or solid state lasers that are
the type of lasers that are used in
lidars and then we started talking about
uh the the characteristics of these
beams of light that are are emitted from
lasers so uh the the physical
description uh basically uh uh uses this
idea of the the paraxial wave
approximation and the idea here is that
uh and and this is general like this is
general you know wave physics uh or or
Optics that any focused Optical beam if
you look uh far down the axis of
propagation it can be approximate
approximated as uh what is called a
paraxial wave so if say uh you take the
z-axis as the optical axis of the of
propagation if you look far down the
z-axis and and just around you know the
the the the the the z-axis so when and Z
is much much bigger than X and Y you
basically can approximate any focused
beam
or the electric field associated with it
as some envelope term so this is some
general function U of X Y and Z okay
that's that's the envelope term so that
determines basically how the the power
is distributed as a function of X Y and
Z times a plane wave term and this is a
plane wave that has a wave Vector that
points in the Z Direction so that's why
instead of e to the minus J K dot R we
just get Norm K times Z because that
inner product when when K is pointing in
the Z Direction just becomes Norm K
times times Z okay so this is general
and then specifically uh if if you look
at the focus beams that are emitted from
lasers
it turns out that this envelope becomes
a gaussian function
or is very I should say very well
approximated by a gaussian function
again this is a this is an approximate
solution but a very very good
approximation
um so in that case we basically have an
envelope that is a gaussian function and
hence these waves are called gaussian
beams so the beams of light that are
emitted by the lasers they're called
gaussian beams and and this should be
familiar because again if you shine any
laser look like a laser pointer on a
flat surface like a wall or a piece of
paper you see this intensity pattern
that is actually a gaussian function
it's bright in the center and then it it
gradually tapers off as you readily move
away from the from the optical center so
the formulation is this so that envelope
term for lasers is given by this complex
valued gaussian Function One Plus Z over
JB Z Plus J B times e to the minus J
times the wave number which is Norm of K
times x squared plus y squared divided
by two Z Plus JV so here you immediately
see the Symmetry with respect to X Y so
the the only place where you have X and
Y is in this x is squared plus y squared
which is the radial diff uh distance
from the optical axis right if this is
your Z
axis x squared any any point that is on
a circle
and this circle is perpendicular this is
a poor drawing but the idea is this is
perpendicular to Z that has x squared
plus y squared that is a constant right
um so so that that you should kind of
see the radial symmetry there which is
expected of a 2d gaussian
and uh from this envelope uh uh so uh if
if you for instance
um from this find the uh the plane or
the Z value at which uh the the the uh
waist size of this gaussian is is uh
discussion envelope is minimized it
turns out to be at Z equals zero okay so
that's called The Beam waste and if you
look at the envelope function at that so
you basically just plug in Z equals zero
into your your equation up above uh your
envelope just becomes one over JB times
e to the minus x squared plus y squared
divided by w0 squared where W 0 is just
this new variable we've introduced uh to
clean up the notation a little bit uh
but it's equal to the square root of
Lambda times B over pi and w0 is called
the beam waste radius okay so
specifically what is that so if you look
at the
um basically if I plot the
um
uh the envelope or the or the
um basically amplitude of the field at
at the Z equals zero plane
so you get this and I'm just going to
draw a cross section of it so you're
going to get this basically gaussian
pattern
um so so this is our basically z-axis
and I'm just doing a cross section here
so plotting the so so I'm just this is a
slightly confusing plot but I'm looking
at the amplitude of the field at the Z
equals zero plane so it's a gaussian
function and what w0 is
is the is the radial distance from the
optical axis at which the field
amplitude drops by 1 over e
okay because if you plug in x squared
plus y squared equals w0 squared you
just get 1 over e this becomes e to the
minus 1 which is one over e so so that's
uh kind of taken as the as the radius so
it's not like the field drops to zero at
w0 uh it's it's a gaussian function so
it just continuously goes on for
any value but most of the energy is
basically contained within
a radius of of w0 at the at the focus
now this also we showed that there is a
couple of important parameters you can
extract from this formulation one is
um let's go to the slide there uh the
so
so we looked at the focus plane just now
and at the focus plane again if you put
a flat surface there you would see this
this 2D
circular gaussian function with a radius
or a 1 over e radius I should say off of
w0
but the the beam doesn't stay at a
constant uh waist radius at a constant
radius so it diverges as it goes past
the focus Point that's that's the
characteristic of any focused beam so
the the wave fronts become convex and it
starts diverging how fast does it
diverge we can calculate the beam radius
this W of Z which is the beam radius
um or I should say the 1 over e being
radius so it's it's again the radius at
which the beam amplitude drops by a
factor of 1 over e as a function of Z so
Z equals zero again is our uh focused
plane and as you go in the positive uh Z
direction as the wave propagates you
start to diverge and this is the exact
expression for uh basically that that
that radius and as you see uh there's a
couple of interesting things here one is
of course it's it's it is diverging so Z
is in the numerator here right so it
does diverge but how quickly uh does it
diverge well it depends on how tightly
we focus the beam because you see this
w0 squared is in the denominator here so
the smaller you focus your beam uh the
faster it is going to diverge as it as
it as it propagates specifically you can
you can find this Divergence angle Theta
D and uh
the derivation is in the notes but it
turns out that Theta D is very well
approximated by Lambda over pi times w0
okay so again smaller w0 means a smaller
focus makes Theta larger which means
faster Divergence okay another thing
which I find interesting is this Lambda
in the in the numerator so that also
means uh well first it it kind of uh
uh tells this this trade-off that we've
seen also in millimeter wave radar and
also in sonar that if you want a more
focused beam you have to go to higher
frequencies right higher frequencies in
this case we know frequency is
speed of light over Lambda so higher
frequency means basically a smaller
smaller lambdas and here smaller Lambda
means better or better collimation so
you can stay more collimated or you
would have a smaller Divergence angle at
smaller wavelengths okay so that's that
and then this this R of the parameter
we're not going to use it much but just
so you know it is the the radius of
curvature off the phase front so as as
we said as you go past the focus point
the the wavefront or the phase fronts
become convex and the actual radius of
curvature of that is is given at a plane
at at
a point Z is given by this RFC parameter
okay so one thing uh if if you plug in
some some typical numbers so say you
have a semiconductor laser and these
devices as we said are very small so
typically uh the the beam waste radius
of a laser beam coming directly out of a
diode uh laser diode is is Micron so it
could be like 10 microns 15 20. it's
it's on that order okay so it's tens of
microns so the W zeros that that you
work with is going to be tens of
micrometers okay and say your wavelength
is like 1550 nanometers Lambda is excuse
me uh with a Lambda of
1550 nanometers if you plug in those
numbers and calculate your Divergence
angle you you come up with very large
Divergence angles tens of degrees
typically like it could be 20 30 up to
50 degrees and um if you remember I I
brought a fiber copper laser last time
and we actually checked it on a piece of
paper it was diverging so quickly that a
few inches away the beam diameter or the
beam radius was so large that it was
obvious it's not using for sensing
applications like lidar because for
lidar you want a beam that stays very
narrow nicely collimated for many many
meters like hundreds of meters you want
a b so what can we do well that's why we
need Optics and bioptics we mean lens
elements because what a lens does it
basically transforms the beam waste
radius for you from some input number w0
to an output that could be much larger
specifically for instance again we
experimented with one lens and I'm going
to just bring up the data sheet of the
lens we looked at so it was a this is
the data sheet of the actual lens that
we use it actually is a doublet lens so
it has two lens elements of inside it
um
so if you look at the data sheet this
lens was designed for 1550 nanometers we
tested it with a red laser which is a
shorter wavelength so it didn't work
quite perfectly but still did a good job
and as part of the data sheet there's
this design MFD mft stands for mode
field diameter so it's basically two
times w0 at the input to the lens and
this one you see it's 10.4 microns which
actually matches the diameter of the
fiber that that that laser was was
coupled to so that's at the input to the
lens
and then it gives you the output 1 over
e squared beam diameter uh we said one
over eight why do these guys say one
over e squared because they're talking
about intensity instead of field and we
know intensity is the square of the
field so same thing but that's the
output beam diameter so that's 2w0 at
the output
of the of the of the lens and you see it
goes from 10 microns to seven
millimeters so that's that's that's the
basically the main effect of of having a
lens in the optical path and now if you
uh basically calculate the Divergence
angle at the output of the lens plugging
in your Lambda which is 1550 nanometers
and your Omega 0 which is now 3.5
millimeters so your Theta d
and you can check this number comes out
to be .016 degrees very small Divergence
angle right so now this beam is going to
stay nice and collimated for hundreds of
meters and it's very useful for sensing
applications
um okay so so hopefully this justifies
why why lenses are needed and what
actually we achieve with them uh then
the question is okay so what is what is
uh the right beam diameter to use for
for lidars and it is a design parameter
that needs to be optimized according to
the application okay so here's one
example and again these this is this is
just one specific example for any
application you need to go through the
exercise and see what the right beam
diameter is but let's say you want to
design a lidar that is supposed to
um work up to 400 meters and then for
your application you want your beam
radius to be smaller than 50 millimeters
at 400 meters okay where did that number
come from well
somebody decided that because beam size
essentially is is one of the main
factors that determines the uh
resolution of your point Cloud right
like that's that's like the pixel size
if you will in a point Cloud so somebody
decided 50 millimeter is a is a radius
that that is required at 400 meters and
then the question is
what beam size should we use
um at the transmitter to achieve this so
the way you can solve this is is
basically we have the expression which
gives us the WFC which is the beam
radius as a function of C and you can
plot that for different values of w0 the
the waist diameter okay you can start
with no Optics and just straight out of
the laser let's say your laser has a 5.2
Micron waist diameter and so if you
don't put any lens then you can plot it
as a function of Z and that gives you
this blue curve here and notice that the
x-axis here is logarithmic so this one
very quickly blows up I mean at one
meter away from your your your laser
you're already way above the requirement
which was 15 millimeters in diameter so
that of course doesn't work then you
start you know sweeping your your W
until you found a value that is that is
satisfactory and in this case at four
millimeters
seems to be meeting the the design
criteria so that that gives us the green
curve which at 400 meters so this is 400
meters
is just below
the 50 Micron requirement
um that that is needed so basically for
this application your collimated Beam at
the transmitter needs to have a radius
of four millimeters or larger okay
larger also works we know but that's
that's kind of the minimum is four
millimeters and then from there you can
do some math and find the basically what
is the focal length that that you need
to get this collimation and then you can
go browse basically
there's vendors who have catalogs of
lenses and you can find a lens or lens
assembly that that basically gives you
the beam diameter that you need with the
focal lengths that you need so that's
that's basically how the optomechanical
design for lidar works
okay any questions
all right so
um let's talk a little more about about
atmospheric effects on on laser beam
propagation so there are two main
atmospheric effects
um when it comes to
beam propagation first one we have
already looked at and that's absorption
we know you know at different
wavelengths there's different absorption
factors in the atmosphere and it also
changes with you know the atmospheric
conditions if there's more moisture in
the atmosphere you know typically it
gets worse
um and then there is the second one
which we're going to talk about now
which is a scattering so scattering is
basically if a collimated beam hits a
particle as it's traveling part of its
energy it's going to randomly scatter in
different directions now the scattering
Behavior highly depends on the ratio of
the aerosol size called that D so those
are the dimensions of these particles in
the atmosphere to the wavelength Lambda
specifically you can be in one of the
three regimes if the aerosols are much
much smaller than your wavelength that
puts you in the so-called Rayleigh
scattering regime and that's for
instance what makes the sky blue the
reason the sky is blue is because of the
Rayleigh scattering that's that's
happening in the atmosphere then you can
be in the museum where your aerosols
dimensions and the wavelengths are
roughly on the same order that puts you
in the so-called me scattering regime
and that's for instance is the effect
that makes the clouds white okay so
clouds have bigger water particles in
them than you know pure atmosphere and
then that that makes me scattering
happening inside the clouds and finally
you can be in a regime where your
aerosol dimensions are much much larger
than your wavelengths and that puts you
in the so-called geometric scattering
regime and that what makes rainbows
basically
um so you see it's you can have very
different physics depending on this
ratio of of uh D2 land now it also turns
out that
um
not only you can get slightly different
physics but also the strength of these
effects are are vastly different so
specifically me scattering is a much
much stronger scattering effect than
Rayleigh scattering am I much much
stronger I mean by many orders of
magnitude
this can become a big problem for lidar
so let's look at an example so let's say
you have fog in the atmosphere and fog
particles typically have diameters of
about like 10 to 50 microns okay now in
this atmosphere if you want to operate a
lidar with a wavelength of 1.5 microns
or 1550 nanometers that puts the lidar
roughly in the me scattering regime it's
roughly on the same order as D Lambda MD
or are kind of close Okay but in the
same atmosphere if you operate a 77
gigahertz radar as we know the
wavelength of the radar is 3.9
millimeters or 3 900 microns so that's
much larger than the than the aerosol
dimensions and puts the radar in the
Rayleigh scattering regime now we just
said that me scattering is a much much
stronger effect than really scattering
and that's why typically lidar gets
degraded or the lighter performance get
degraded much more than radar when it
comes to you know poor atmospheric
conditions like rain and fall and things
like that okay so so that's just one
thing to note
and that's why again generally lidar is
much more susceptible to atmospheric
effects than than radar
so when it comes to me scattering which
is the main kind of scattering that
affects lidar performance it actually
hurts the lighter performance in two
different ways okay so let's look at the
pictures here here we're showing a
gaussian beam traveling left to right
okay and then as it's traveling it hits
some uh some aerosol shown in blue here
and then me scattering happens okay so
as I said when scattering happens this
scattered energy can can go in any any
direction basically so we can have back
scattering so some of that energy
scatters backwards basically towards the
the transmitter and you can also have
forward scattering in in different
angles
uh now here you see the two effects
because if you had some Target here
well first because of the scattering
some of the transmitted light would not
hit the target right it just gets
scattered in random directions wouldn't
make its way to the Target so that would
reduce the SNR because now less of your
transmitted light is is going to make it
uh or be incident on target so naturally
you get less echo or a reflected light
back so that's the first thing that
degrades the performance with the me
scattering but also some of these back
scattered light can make its way back to
the receiver and show as real targets
right especially if it's strong enough
which happens when the particles are
smaller smaller particles typically give
more more back scattering than larger
particles so some of that back scattered
light would show as false positives in
the detector so you see there's there's
there's two effects really happening
here so here's just a picture showing
like again you have your lidar operating
in fog or rain or you know some highly
scattering medium
uh and then the two effects that hurt
you like some of these
um
scattering events would would have
Backscatter that makes it its way back
to the to the lidar and that will show
us false positives but also you would
have because of all the energy that got
scattered away randomly throughout this
atmosphere naturally you get less light
incident on the target which reduces
your SNR
so basically to summarize SNR goes down
false positive goes up when when you
have multiple scattering medium for
lighter
here's one experiment we ran to kind of
quantify this effect so in this
experiment
um it's it's uh it's in a room and and
we have a Target it's just a mannequin
that is set in the room and we have a
fog machine so we can kind of in a
semi-controlled way generate a fog with
different different densities inside the
room left column shows uh basically a
camera looking into the room and right
right column shows Point clouds from a
lidar that is looking into the same room
and in this case we were using a
velodyne vlp 32c lidar when uh first a
top row is uh when you have light fog
okay so there's as you see in the camera
view there's a little bit of fog
um so that's why you have reduced
contrast on the target but not too dense
okay and then uh you get you look at
your uh lighter Point Cloud it's mostly
fine but you do get a little bit of
false positives you see like these
floating
particles that are detected uh and
mid-air those are from back scattered
light causing some false positives but
it's mostly okay I mean it's not it's
not horrible but then as you increase
your fog density if you go to a heavy
fog case well camera gets completely
impaired almost right you can't make out
the Target
lidar also is now heavily impaired as
you see you get uh very high false
positives almost it's almost like the
wall is is just you know continuing
across there's no opening you still have
some detections on your target but with
much reduced SNR and as you can see this
this can then become a real problem
because then in such cases in your lidar
map your false positives look like real
obstacles right so this is a challenging
case where where basically if you were
to do autonomy in such a k it's such a
you know condition and camera is not
much help right light is really really
degraded so this is a case where you
would need to for instance heavily rely
on your radar which wouldn't get
degraded in in such a such a scenario
and this kind of illustrates illustrates
why you need complementarity of of
different sensing modalities
there are I should say things you can do
to reject
some of these false positive detections
in lidars and with smarter you know
signal processing algorithms but none of
The Radars out in the market today do
those so pretty much like any any
off-the-shelf
lidar you buy this is the kind of
behavior you would get from them in in
poor atmospheric conditions
any questions
okay uh let's continue so um as we said
um when it comes to illuminating the
scene there's there's two uh uh
basically main techniques that lidars
use one was flashlight R which was
exactly like flash Photography in one
shot basically they generate very wide
beams of of laser so those do not use
gaussian beams essentially they actually
put instead of collimating Optics they
use diffusing Optics which are these
diffusing elements that generate very
wide beams so they can illuminate the
entire scene in one shot
but most of the lidars actually use
gaussian beams and then they have beam
scanning mechanisms that just scan this
pencil being across some field of view
and then that's how they illuminate the
scene so I want to talk a little bit
about different beam scanning techniques
so there are two main categories of beam
scanning techniques uh when it comes to
lidars first one is solid state beam
scanning so solid state beam scanners
are basically techniques that pretty
much don't have big uh moving mechanical
Parts okay that's mainly what
distinguishes them so those are things
like mems mirror arrays Liquid Crystal
arrays Optical phase arrays and Electro
Optical beam scanners these are very
attractive Technologies again because
they can be very compact very low power
and very robust because they don't have
big moving Parts but as of today
most of these Technologies are not quite
mature for you know widespread field
deployment they are deployed you know in
in limited cases but they're mostly
still under development for for lidar
I'm sure soon enough we'll we'll get
them you know get to the maturity level
that we'll see more of those but as of
today most of the beam scanning
techniques that are used are not in
lidars are not are not solidisted
they're actually mechanical uh beam
scanning techniques so mechanical beam
scanning as the name suggests these have
you know big moving mechanical parts
that are used to scan the beam
and there's two types of them either
basically the entire you know
transmitter with the laser and
everything is moved you know you fix the
laser to a frame and just move that
frame things like rotating frame beam
scanners do that which is extremely
common or you have some sort of optical
elements like prisms or mirrors in the
path of the laser beam and move those
elements to scan the beam so you can
have things like prism scanners gavel
mirrors scanners or electrostatic or
polygon mirrors as we'll see okay
some examples some pictures mostly to so
you get more familiar with both the
solid state and mechanical beam scanners
here are some pictures of solid estate
Beam Beam scanners so top left is a mems
scanner okay so so you have your mirror
at the center
and then you have some electrostatic
actuators exactly basically same type of
architecture that we saw in gyroscopes
and accelerometers you have these you
know comb Drive actuators basically that
um actuate the the generate some
movement and then they can basically
move the mirror in a a and generate some
pitch and roll and so your mirror can
move into axes and then you have some
incident beam which is fixed and then
the output beam basically is a scanned
in two axes as the mirror pivots then
you can have your liquid Crystal scanner
so Liquid Crystal is uh it has a
basically basically LCD array Liquid
Crystal array and the Liquid Crystal by
controlling the phase of the pixels
inside the Liquid Crystal array you can
deflect the beam in in in different
directions
interesting technology but it can be
lossy and it can generate side lobes so
your outgoing beam can might not be a
nice gaussian anymore and it can be slow
so those are the reasons and this is all
today right I mean this is a not
fundamental limitations of the
technology but this is why why it's not
widely deployed today about mems uh what
are the limitations of mems today well
one is the size of the mirrors I mean
you know mems devices are you know very
small scale devices so this mirror
um
these tend to be very small so you can't
have like a I don't know giant you know
five four five millimeter beam just
hitting one mirror you can make a mirror
array
um and and you know scan all of them
together
um but then that also there's a limit to
you know how well you can synchronize
all of those mirrors and also uh there's
some uh mechanical reliability issues
with these mems scanners today
specifically for
um you know applique robotic
applications where robustness is Key
like Automotive applications these are
these are not a great fit as of today
then you can have Electro Optical
scanners so these use Electro Optical
effects typically you have two
electrodes on the device One controls in
Phase uh sorry in-plane angle and and
the other one controls out of plane you
can think of it as Azimuth and elevation
control for the outgoing beam and
typically the way they work is that by
applying these voltages to the
electrodes they modulate the a
refractive index of the medium that the
light is traveling through and by doing
that you can deflect light in different
different directions so you have a fixed
input beam and a scanned output being
basically out of those devices and
finally you can have Optical phase array
scanners
extremely attractive technology not
super mature today but the core idea
here is exactly like phase array radar
that we looked at if you remember with
phase array radar we said if you have
multiple antennas that that are
transmitting by applying a relative
phase between those antennas you can
basically
deflect the effective outgoing radar
beam in different directions you can do
exact same idea and Optics I mean this
is the same physics right it's
electromagnetic wave so the way this
works except this works at much smaller
scales because wavelengths are much
smaller so you have your incoming
basically that's that's your laser diode
it's coupled to a waveguide
coming in so this is all on a say a
silicon wafer and then you split That
Into You Know multiple wave guides okay
um so that's this you know tree
structure is just like splitting the
light and then you have a bunch of phase
modulators in the path of each of these
waveguides and then you can control the
the the
phases uh the delays of these individual
waveguides and then at the output you
kind of bring them together right very
closely and then that becomes your
essentially output aperture and then by
controlling the phases you can scan the
outgoing beam in different directions
okay so that's uh that's all of the
state now let's look at some mechanical
beam scanning techniques and again today
uh most of the light as you see use use
mechanical beam scanners
um I'm sure it will change eventually
solid state will will become the
dominant technology but that's not the
case today
so uh
specifically most of the lidars today
use this rotating frame mechanical beam
scanner it's a it's a pretty simple
mechanical architecture so basically uh
they have multiple lasers inside okay so
that's why in this picture you see you
know there is there's multiple laser
beams coming out each is from a
individual laser diode and each is
pointing into a fixed elevation angle
okay so the elevation angles of the
outgoing beams are just fixed by
construction and you can have I've seen
any number between 16 and 128 outgoing
beams of course more means you get you
know better elevation resolution and
then the entire frame
uh where the these lasers and the
corresponding photo detectors are
mounted uh basically rotates so it's it
has a motor that that rotates the whole
thing a full 360 Degrees
um and it can go at angular velocities
minimum is 10 Hertz but some of them go
faster 15 20 30 Hertz and that's how you
get these ring-like scan patterns so
essentially each if like if you look at
the these that's the point Cloud shown
around the car the lidar is mounted at
the top of the car and then you have
these you know beams coming out and each
beam as rotates it just scans like a
circle around the around the lighter so
that's how you get you know these
ring-like patterns and as you see uh the
result is you get you know very good
resolution on each ring in uh in Azimuth
right but elevation is is pretty coarse
and discreet and and that's determined
by the number of beams that you have and
how they're placed there's different
strategies for you know pointing the or
deciding the elevation angles of the
outgoing being some some lighters do
uniform some of them have some gradient
like this is a specific one you see it
it's it's denser towards the horizon
because this was optimized for driving
applications where you know most of the
interesting stuff is on the road and
mostly at you know at Horizon level so
it gets a little coarser in elevation
above Horizon and also below Horizon
it's a little coarse anyway so this is
this is one of the dominant ways there
there are other techniques and this next
one is a is a pretty interesting like
from a engineering and scientific point
of view I I find it fascinating but
practically it's kind of questionable
and and I'll I'll tell you why but uh
it's called Risley prisms I think it was
developed by Lockheed Martin and uh it
was used in some early lidars and
fighter jets it's a very cool idea so
there's some incident beam coming at an
um on an optical axis and then they have
two uh round prisons which have
wedge-like cross-sections so that's
prism one that's prism two and then if
you look at the cross section of the two
you see they're like wedges okay so um
just by the effect of uh uh refracting
the light so the incident beam it
basically gets refracted twice uh once
as it enters each prism and once as it
exits okay and then and and it goes out
at some angle
and then by rotating the two two prisms
so the two prisons are mounted on you
know rotating frames so they can rotate
about the optical axis of the system at
different uh different angular
velocities Omega 1 and Omega two so by
just controlling the the ratio of Omega
1 and Omega 2 you can generate different
scan patterns of the outgoing beam so
here are two examples uh they're these
like rosetta-like patterns that you get
so if you have a ratio of two to one uh
you get this if you have a ratio of ten
to one you get the more dense looking
pattern so it's pretty cool and there is
at least one lidar company called liveox
that that that uses this but the scan
patterns are kind of irregular right and
you have some control over it but it's
it's it's it's it's it's weird the way
you control it like you can't have
regular you know grid like
scan patterns that are more desirable
typically so you kind of you get what
you get but it's an interesting
technology
um and then you can have mechanical
scanners that just use mirrors basically
so you put a mirror in the path or one
or a few mirrors in the path of the
laser beam and move the mirrors to scan
the beam so here's the electrostatic
scanner you have this round gold uh gold
plated mirror you have your input beam
and output beam and then there's
electrostatic actuators that basically
uh uh uh move the mirror or pivot the
mirror about two axes and then you can
have a two axis beam scanner these are
highly configurable right because
depending on like what waveform you send
to the X and Y actuators you can
generate different output scan patterns
so they're highly flexible in terms of
scan pattern generation then uh here's
another very common one the galvo
scanner so galvo scanner just has two
independent Motors these are mounted
inside these brackets so so there's
there's one motor here year basically
and then there's another motor here and
each motor basically a mirror is mounted
to the to the output you know output of
the mirror so you can pivot the two
mirrors in in in two axes so you get two
bounces you have your input beam bounces
off the first mirror and then bounces
off the second mirror and then you have
your output scan beam so one mirror
basically controls the the Azimuth angle
of the outgoing beam and the other
mirror controls the elevation angle and
again this is a highly highly
configurable uh you know scanner you can
design different scan patterns for the
or different waveforms for the two
mirrors that give you different output
scan patterns so these are very
attractive for instance in research
applications because they don't lock you
into a fixed scan pattern and you can
also generate dynamically varying scan
patterns and things like that which is
not the case for for instance this
rotating frame scanners and finally you
can have your polygon mirror scanner so
so this one is it is actually used in an
industry quite a bit because it's cheap
and robust but not very configurable so
you have this polygon where the output
uh faces our mirrors and it rotates at
some angular velocity so
you have this input beam and then the
output beam
um as as the polygon rotates it's going
to just scan in One Direction so this
gives you a 1D scanning it just does say
um Azimuth for instance you can use two
of them to do to do more than one but
typically you just get a one axis
scanning
okay questions yes
so those are typically spinning like I
don't know how fast you're spinning but
are you like sending and receiving as
it's like spinning like that fast you
just assume that it happened yes so the
question is for these uh rotating frame
lidars
um are we sending and receiving the
signal as it's rotating and the answer
is yes
so that's why part of the reason they
can rotate too fast is exactly because
of that because
um if if you scan too fast
um basically by the time you receive the
echo back from the target especially if
it's a far Target you have rotated so
much that the the echo that returns
might not align with your detector
anymore and that reduces your SNR
significantly so typically SNR one of
the factors that determines the SNR of
these devices is how fast they spin okay
but uh kind of related to that that's
kind of the case for any scanning
mechanism so even like with the Gallow
scanner if you scan your mirrors too
fast I mean it's the same thing you send
out a beam and then it hits a Target so
the echo that comes back by the time it
comes back if your mirror is pointing at
a significantly different angle you
can't collect that Echo so that's a
general trade-off that you have for
lidars scanning lidars which is
regardless of your beam scanning
technique if you scan too fast it's
gonna your SNR is going to start to drop
do you have to go ahead
doing it really direction of arrival or
is it just like you know where you're
sending it and you're probably gonna get
a great question and and we'll talk a
little more about this uh towards the
end of the chapter but generally there's
generally speaking there's no DSP
because you know like regardless of
again whatever scanning mechanism you're
using uh you you know you model it right
some of them is is easy right like if
you have like for instance for this one
where you just have one mirror and you
know uh one reflection just by by
knowing the angle the mirror is pointing
to
um you just know your direction of
arrival right some of them are slightly
more complicated so for instance for
this one you have to have a model
because what you re what you know is
like Omega Omega 1 and Omega 2 or the
orientation of the two prisms at a given
point in time so you have to have you
know a function that maps that to the
angle of the outgoing beam but you
generally assume that the angle you're
pointing to that's also your angle of
arrival for for lidar
um gavel also um you need to kind of
model it because you get two Reflections
and there is a very specific kind of
distortion that can happen if you don't
model you know the gavel geometry
correctly
okay so uh next next topic is photo
detection but let's quickly remind
ourselves where we are so when we
started talking about the lidar physics
this is basically the picture we had so
so far we have learned about laser
sources we have learned about basically
these gaussian beams that that come out
of the source we've talked about a TX
Optics or lenses that basically
collimate a fastly diverging beam to a
nice nice collimated beam that can
travel hundreds of meters right we have
also talked about beam scanning
techniques so that's also done now we're
going to start talking about photo
detection okay
so
uh photo detection what is photo
detection so generally speaking photo
detection is the process of absorbing
photons of fly light and transforming
them into a detectable signal okay and a
detectable signal can be different
things in different applications it
might be heat in some applications it
could be electrical current or voltage
or or other things right for lidar uh
it's it's basically electrical current
that's that's uh what what we'll work
with so we want devices that can absorb
these photons that are reflected from
the targets and convert them to electric
current because then we can use all the
you know good techniques that we have
developed in electronics we can convert
current to voltage fix the voltage to a
analog to digital converter and then you
know do signal processing on it but
generally speaking there's there's
different types of photo detection
phenomena that can happen you can have
biological photo detection that's for
instance what happens in our eyes the
photons are absorbed and then it goes
through a complex sequence of of
chemical reactions and eventually
produces a signal in a nervous system
for instance that's one type of photo
detection you can have thermal photo
detection where photons are absorbed and
they are transformed to into heat so
devices like thermos stores for instance
do that you can have photoacoustic
detection pretty interesting phenomena
where photons are absorbed and they're
transformed into sound waves directly
that that that can happen very
interesting and and finally you can have
the photoelectric effect which is the
one again that lidars use for sensing
and that's where they absorb photons
essentially free up electrons that
generate an electric current inside a
device and then this current is
eventually converted to a voltage that
is used for sensing okay so we are going
to focus
on the photoelectric effect and study
the physics of devices that are that are
used specifically semiconductor
photoelectric detectors is is what is
used widely used in liners okay so there
are
when it comes to photo detectors in
short we are going to call them PDS uh
there is there's two main
characteristics that are very important
for sensing for these devices one is
called the responsivity of the device
and the responsivity is basically a
measure of how efficiently the photo
detector converts the photons to
electrons okay or Optical input to
electrical output that's that's a
measure of efficiency okay so that's
number one that is very important and
obviously we want responsibility as high
as possible right we want the device to
be as efficient as possible and then
there is a notion of bandwidth and
bandwidth is basically determines how
fast the device responds or or how
quickly it can respond to a change in
Optical input
okay
it comes to bandwidth
um
the bandwidth is a parameter you need to
optimize to get the best sensing
performance and what I mean by
optimizing is that the bandwidth needs
to be matched to the the characteristics
of the the signal waveforms that you
send out right you want to you want to
have enough bandwidth that you can make
sure you would capture whatever waveform
that you sent okay but if you have more
than that if you have excess bandwidth
that's not necessarily a good thing
because that means there is just some
additional noise that can make it into
your signal and reduce SNR okay so
responsivity we want it high but
bandwidth we want it optimized I'm just
going to put a starter for for optimized
okay and we're going to talk about both
of these but we'll start with the
physics of the device and the and the
responsivity again there's lots of
different photo detection mechanisms and
for each mechanism there's different
devices that you know operate based on
that that mechanism but specifically for
for lidar the type of photo detectors
that are used are called the the pin
semiconductor photodive okay so what is
this device
this device is actually it's a diode
okay if you're if you're familiar uh uh
with with with diode so so it's just uh
uh from if if you want to just you know
reduce it to a component electrical
component it's actually a diode so it
has a a positive terminal and a negative
terminal an anode and a cathode okay but
you might know generally diodes they're
used of uh they're they're made of two
types of semiconductors a p-type and an
n-type semiconductor what what are what
is a p-type and n-type so a p-type
semiconductor is a semiconductor that is
doped with uh additional atoms which has
excess positive charge carriers okay so
this is the p-type which has you know
excess positive charges
and an n-type semiconductor is a
semiconductor material that is doped
with some other material that has excess
negative charge carriers or electrons so
this is this is our n-type which has
excess negative charges okay
so so if you just put a p and an N type
semiconductor together you get a regular
diode which has its own applications for
instance rectification it used a lot in
Power Electronics but that is not useful
for photo detection the magic happens
when you add a third material which is
called the intrinsic
material and the intrinsic material is
just some undoped
semiconductor a third material that you
kind of sandwich in between and that
part of the device is called also called
the depletion region okay because it's
depleted of it's naturally depleted of
charge carriers it's not doped okay
and what happens if if you choose you
know the right right materials and make
a pin diode it's still a diode but it's
a very special type of diode that in
addition to the the the regular
electrical characteristics of the diode
it also can do a photo conversion for
you uh via the photoelectric effect so
what happens is that if there's some
incident photons uh on the on the
depletion region of the device
um
if the photons are of the right energy
and by right energy I mean if the energy
of the photons which is given by H times
f h remember is the Planck's Constant
and F is the frequency of of the photons
if it's bigger than or equal to some
Delta e which is called the band Gap
energy of this semiconductor material in
the intrinsic region and that's a
property of the material every material
has some every semiconductor has some
intrinsic band Gap so photons that have
energy that is bigger than or equal to
that can get absorbed
and create electron hole pairs so one
Photon gets absorbed and it generates a
positive charge carrier and a negative
charge carrier okay and then what
happens is that inside the intrinsic
region there is this electric field
which is generated because you have
accumulation of positive charges on one
side and negative charges on the other
side so this electric field basically
sweeps away the electron hole pair that
are generated and as a result you get a
photo current inside the device
okay so again a photon enters the
depletion region or the or the
photosensitive region of the device and
if it's of the right energy it can
generate a electron hole pair and then
the electric field that is inside this
intrinsic region basically sweeps them
in in opposite directions basically the
electron goes to the anode side the the
the the
hole goes to the cathode side and that
means you generate a photocurrent inside
the device so so that's how basically at
the physics level uh this this device
device works
most important characteristic of the
device is how what's the efficiency of
this conversion of photons to electrons
right through this
basically effect that we just just
described
not
yeah
they said the holes are going to the
left
um can you can you explain why they're
like why the plus and the minuses are
going
um in those directions
uh because because that's a Direction so
it's determined by the direction of the
electric field right so so here here see
like the inside the region uh that the
depletion region you have this electric
field that goes in this direction okay
and then the fourth step is applied if
you have a positive charge it's going to
get so at this way if you have a
negative charge it's going to get
swapped in the opposite direction
the the battery that you have the
voltage that will affect it right
especially we'll talk more about that so
that's the bias voltage that you apply
will affect the electric field but it
turns out that even if I disconnect the
battery okay
I need to close the circuit to to use
the signals but even without that there
is some intrinsic feel that is always
present inside the depletion region and
that's because of this diffusion effect
that you know some of the negative
charges you know get get diffused and
and accumulate at the at the border of
the p uh side and some positive charges
you know diffuse and get accumulated
that's actually how the intrinsic region
works you know you get you know this
this carrier diffusion effect and there
is some surface positive charge and on
the on the on the cathode side under
some surface negative charge on the
anode side and those charges create this
intrinsic electric field
um that is that is always always present
and it goes positive to negative but if
you apply an external bias voltage it
will it can reinforce that field or
reduce it depending on whether your bias
voltage is positive or negative
so I guess like
um I guess like what why why would you
apply it lives just like uh we'll get to
that it's yeah why why do we apply the
bias that's hopefully we can cover it
today but that's a great question why
bias
um and and do one positive Y is negative
bias or what okay so first thing is is
this idea of the efficiency of the
device which is uh basically it's called
Quantum efficiency fancy term but all
that basically captures is the ratio of
the electron flux that you get generated
inside the device to the photon flux
that is incident on the depletion region
or the photo photosensitive region of
the device it's called Ado sub Q so it's
basically the ratio of electrons per
second that are generated to the photons
per second that are incident on the
device now there's three factors that
affect the this this efficiency right
first one is not every Photon that is
incident actually makes its way into the
intrinsic region some of them just get
as as you see here some of them just get
reflected away okay so if you have some
surface reflectivity called that R of
the device one minus r is the is the
ratio or percentage of of the num the
photons that actually make their way
into the photosensitive region okay now
once they're inside they need to get
absorbed because some of them also would
just pass right through without getting
absorbed and those also don't contribute
to the to the photo current there's two
factors that determine
um that this this absorption coefficient
what what this absorption effect
basically one is Alpha which is the
photon absorption coefficient and that's
a property of the material I'll show you
some curves but there's like for every
given material at every or every given
semiconductor at every given wavelength
there is some intrinsic you know
absorption coefficient
so How deep the depletion region is so D
is basically this
depth of the device of course if more
depth means there's more time for the
electrons for the photons to get
absorbed as the as they're going uh
through the device okay so you put these
two together and the ratio of the
photons that get absorbed you can
quantify that by 1 minus E to the minus
Alpha d right so for instance if your
Alpha is zero means no absorption
coefficient like no intrinsic absorption
this term just becomes small minus one
which is zero so that makes it useless
of course pi and photodiode but the
larger out the alpha is or the larger D
is that makes this term closer to one
okay
finally the third effect which affects
the efficiencies the fact that not every
electron hole pair so after a photon is
absorbed and it generates an electron
hole pair not all of them are swept away
and contribute to the photo current some
of them just after they get created they
just recombine back and get get
basically destroyed so the fraction so
this PSI is the fraction of electron
hole pairs that do not recombine and get
swept away and contribute to the to the
photo current so that's the third term
you just multiply all three and that
gives you your total Quantum efficiency
so 1 minus reflectivity surface Rift
activity times PSI times the absorption
ratio and that's the total number of
electrons per second to photons per
second that you get okay
now uh
as I said this absorption coefficient
Alpha is a function of the semiconductor
material and wavelength so you have
curves basically for absorption
coefficient say in in one one over
centimeter as a function of wavelength
for different materials so different
materials are shown in different colors
and then you can you know say you want
to build a lighter at 15 50 nanometers
and then you look at the curves and what
are the choices germanium is a good
choice even better is Indian gallium
arsenide okay or you want to build a
lidar at 905 what choices do we have you
could use silicon not the the the most
efficient but it works you can use
indium phosphide or even better you can
use indium gallium arsenide okay and
there's of course different silicon is
cheap so that's why it's used a lot but
in gas is a more expensive exotic
material but more efficient
we'll see in the next chapter when we
talk about cameras so camera wavelengths
are down here right so they're like 400
actually they're even further down
so not even shown here but it's it's
from point four
macrons to 0.7 so that's visible light
and for visible light
which is here you would see silicon
becomes pretty good at those wavelengths
so that's why
um the the the image sensors in
invisible light cameras most of them are
are made in Silicon because it's it's
it's cheap and pretty good at those
wavelengths okay
because Quantum efficiency relates
electrons per second to Photon so
electron flux to Photon flux right
electrons per second photons per second
those are not natural units to work with
we don't want to like count electrons or
count photons we like to work with
currents and power right those are more
you know uh intuitive parameters to work
with so there's this little conversion
you can do to relate Quantum efficiency
to what is called the responsivity of
the photodiode what the responsivity is
is assume some Photon flux Phi so that's
the number of photons per second that is
incident on the photodiode uh what is
the power of that Photon flux so power
is the energy of the photons times the
flux again energy is Planck's constant
times the the frequency and frequency
remember it's speed of light over Lambda
so that's the total power that's
incident on the device and what is the
current that you get out of the device
the current is just the electric charge
e times the electron flux okay so I sub
P which is the photo current you can
write it as the quantum efficiency times
the elementary charge the charge of the
electron times the photon flux okay so
again this Photon flux times ETA that
gives you the electron flux and electron
flux times e gives you the electric
current in amps okay now in terms of the
optical power this becomes the
expression so you're so here you have
your current in amps and this is power
in watts of optical power in Watts okay
it becomes ETA times e over HF times P
that's the relationship between
electrical photo current in amps and
Optical power in Watts
responsivity are
is defined as basically the ratio of the
photo current to the incident Optical
power ISO p over P which becomes equal
to your Quantum efficiency times the
charge of the electron divided by
Planck's constant times the frequency of
the incident light you can write this in
terms of wavelength using this equation
here relates frequency to wavelength and
in terms of the wavelength you get this
very famous equation for responsivity so
becomes your Quantum efficiency times
the wavelength divided by some constant
1 over 2 2 2.4 so this is r and we are
slightly overloading our in our notation
we've used R for reflectivity previously
this this is the responsivity and it's
in amps per watt right how many amps of
current you get out of the photodiode
for every wad of incident Optical power
interesting thing is that of course the
higher the quantum efficiency the better
okay you can get pretty close to one
with modern devices in Quantum
efficiency
but also interestingly it goes up
linearly with Lambda so higher
wavelength gives you higher
responsibility typically
um let's look at some responsivity
curves again for different materials so
here we are comparing silicon and indium
gallium arsenide okay but this time
we're looking at the full responsivity
of the device in amps per one okay again
as we said at 1550 and gas is the
material of choice it can get
responsibility on the order of one
roughly amps per watt
that's a nice high number and silicon is
is slightly lower but it's it's it's
pretty useful at you know visible light
even at at 905 you know silicon and in
gas in terms of the responsivity they're
they're pretty close so that's why
silicon is used in 905 nanometer lidars
also
uh interesting thing here is this linear
Trend right so we just said that that
responsivity
goes up with wavelengths that you kind
of see it in these two curves uh why
does the care for each material drop
outside a specific band because as we
said for the photons to get absorbed the
energy of the photons needs to be close
to the band Gap energy of that material
the Delta e right so so so this is
basically for instance that the the
wavelengths which makes the photons
absorbable by and gas because they're
you know close to the band Gap energy
and if you're much more or much less
than that the material just cannot
absorb efficiently those those photons
and that's why the responsibility starts
to drop okay any questions
all right so we talked about a
responsivity uh here's how these devices
are fabricated
in Silicon pretty simple fabrication so
you have a cathode which is just you
know a solid uh electric plate basically
uh you have your n-type semiconductor
deposited then you deposit your
intrinsic material which is the photo or
a sensitive region then you have a
p-type material and kind of like a
well-like manner deposited at the top
you need a second electrode to make the
anode so those are kind of constructed
like a frame around the the p-type
semiconductor and then you you need some
aperture opening because light needs to
get into the intrinsic region so that's
that's basically this purple looking
material that's a anti-reflection
coating why do we put anti-reflection
coating because we just said to improve
a Quantum efficiency if you apply
anti-reflection coating uh you you
reduce the percentage of the photons
that get reflected out and more of them
make their ways into the intrinsic
region which just helps Quantum
efficiency and responsibility of the
device so so that's why anti-reflection
coding is applied and here you see two
silicon Pi on photodias that are
constructed and these have pretty large
apertures as you see in the pictures
kind of big
um so simple construction and that's why
these devices are kind of like cheap and
and reliable okay
next thing we need to talk about is this
idea of dark current and what dark
current is is that
um
it's kind of a quantum mechanical effect
so you can't quite get into the physics
of it but it turns out that uh except if
you hold your device at Absolute Zero
temperature which practically is not
possible there's always going to be some
current following through the photo
diode even when there's no incident
light so even in the absence of incident
light there is going to be some small
current going through the device and
that is called the dark current
uh so this darken essentially becomes
like a noise source for uh photo sensing
right because there is some current that
even even when there's no light it
actually uh is present and uh so given a
photodiode with with some darker and I
sub s uh the minimum Optical power that
that you can detect with the device P
Min is typically taken by the power that
corresponds to a photo current that is
at least equal to the dark current
because the idea here is that if if the
insulin power is so low such that the
corresponding photocurrent is lower than
the dark current it's kind of like your
below noise floor and and not not
detectable so you can just do this
simple math what is IP man that's just
the incident power minimum times the
responsibility of your photodiode and if
you want that to be equal at least well
technically you want to be bigger than
or equal but the minimum level goes when
you are equal to your darker and that
limits sets a limit on your minimum
detectable Optical power which is the
darker and divided by the responsibility
of your device now for good devices the
dark currents are are very very small I
mean they can be like
sub microamp or even like Nano amp or in
really really good devices like pico amp
level
but but that essentially sets sets a
bound on on on the smallest Optical
power you can detect
okay so we talked about the responsivity
of devices but we also said when it
comes to photo detection the bandwidth
of the device also matters and that's
how fast it responds to Optical inputs
so
bandwidth of the device is very closely
related to this idea of the response
time of the device so let's look at the
pictures down here here we are having a
step-like change in the incident Photon
flux
onto a photo detector so it's at some
you know low level and at some time zero
it just jumps to a higher level that's
Photon flux and then if you look at the
response of the device and the response
can be you know the change in the in the
in the photo current or if you convert
the photo current to the voltage the
change in the voltage but the electrical
response that you get out of your PD
it's not going to be like a step it's
it's always a smoother function so in
this case the device is going to take
some time which is called the response
time to say go from 0 to 90 percent of
its final value okay and that's that's
TR
uh and when it comes to the response
time there's two effects that determine
the response time of of the device one
is the called the charge carrier Transit
time so that means basically how how
long does it take for this for an
average electron hole pair that is
generated inside the intrinsic region to
be swept away and and generate some
current Now transit times are extremely
fast for these devices because they just
need to travel you know uh uh um a
sub Micron you know distances so
typically Transit time is very fast and
what really determines the response time
T sub R of the device turns out to be
the RC time constant of the photodiode
uh what is RC time constant so typically
you have some external readout circuitry
we'll talk about that more and R is the
resistance of that readout circuitry so
now we are even triply overloading our
rvv today we used R for three different
things for reflectivity for
responsibility and now for resistance
hopefully by context is clear which it's
referring to so so R is the readout
circuitry resistance in ohms
and C is the photodiode Junction
capacitance because if you look at the
construction of the photodiode and we'll
look at it in more detail in the next
slide it well it's a diode but it also
has some Junction capacitance because it
has two parallel plates with charges
built up on them so as as you you know
from elementary circuit Theory when you
have an RC circuit the time constant of
that circuit which is how fast it
responds to changes that the input is
determined by R times C so your response
time of your photodiode is proportional
to R times C which means the bandwidth
of the device which is the inverse of
the the the the response time is
proportional to 1 over RC so if you want
faster devices you need to decrease r or
decrease C or both okay uh
C is basically intrinsic to the junction
construction uh so by by changing the
geometry of the of the pin photodiode
you can actually affect c as as as we'll
see and that is typically a technique
that is not so let's look at the
junction capacitance of a pin photodiode
as we said this is the device
construction and you have two electrodes
right
positive and negative with some charge
build up so that makes a parallel plate
capacitor what is the capacitance of a
parallel plate capacitor as we know it's
Epsilon zero times Epsilon R Epsilon R
is the relative uh primitivity of the
semiconductor material okay times a a is
the cross-sectional area of the device
right so it's basically in this picture
it's the area in and out of the plane
that's the area of the plates of this
parallel plate capacitor divided by the
separation of the two plates which is
the the width of the device w
okay so that determines your Junction
capacitance and if we can somehow lower
C that improves the bandwidth of the
device makes the device faster
so of course as you fabricate a device
you can control materials and geometry
and and that's one way of of uh you know
by Design reducing C but if you're given
a photodiode which is already fabricated
you don't have control over a
or Epsilon but it turns out
interestingly you do have some control
over w
and it's uh back to Sarah's question
that's one place where this bias voltage
V sub D that you apply externally to the
device becomes important because
um bias voltage is is you know the
external circuitry that is this device
is part of always you know apply some
bias voltage uh to it but it turns out
that if this bias voltage is is chosen
to be negative
okay if it's chosen to be negative uh
what what it will do is that it will
reinforce this electric field inside the
the depletion region okay and by
increasing that e field uh basically it
will increase the depression Region's
width because you get more carrier
diffusion right so you get you know more
more uh of of the carriers diffusing to
the two sides and it kind of stretches
the width of the device by applying that
negative external bias voltage so w goes
up
if if you're uh you're you're reverse
biasing your device which means the
junction capacitance goes down and that
helps the bandwidth of the device so
that's the first reason why reverse
biasing essentially a pin photodiode is
a good thing because it helps bandwidth
now it turns out that there's a second
reason which is much much more important
uh why you you would want to uh reverse
bias a a pin diode and to understand
that we need to look at the complete
voltage current characteristic of this
device so remember we started with
saying this pin devices are diodes right
there are special types of diodes that
are sensitive to incident Optical power
and generate photocurrents but there are
still diodes and as you know every diode
the it has a exponential relationship
between the current that goes through it
and a voltage that is applied to its
terminals so a regular diode if you
remember from your electronics course
the the voltage current relationship is
well ignore this term for now
is given by this exponential function
which is I sub D is the current that is
goes through the device and V sub D is
the voltage applied to the two terminals
of the diode okay so so you have some uh
V sub d
applied and then there's some I sub D
going through the device and regular
diodes have this relationship which is
this constant is which in this case
turns out to be the dark current times e
to the magnitude of the elementary
charge times V sub D divided by K sub B
is the boltzmann constant given by this
number here times the absolute
temperature minus one okay so that's
just the diode effect there now for pin
diodes because they're special they have
this additional term which is the photo
current
and that's due to all the physics that
we just talked about so for a pin diode
the full IV characteristic or the
behavior of the device is essentially
the the sum of the two effects you have
you know the normal diode current
plus the photo current uh well why is
the plus actually a minus here because
uh the minus in front of the IP is
because the photo current as we saw uh
flows from the N terminal to the P
terminal but the convention for
electrical clearance is that it flows
from P to n so ID is always taken in
this direction but we saw that IP
actually flows in the opposite direction
so that's why we put the we put the
minus sign there
okay so uh
what we are actually let me clean this
up got a bit too messy uh so what we are
really interested in for sensing is just
IP the photo current
all the this stuff is just you know
noise or interference for us that we are
not interested in okay but by the
physics of the device because it's a
diode it's there okay so if you want to
limit or eliminate this term
the only option we have if you look at
this exponential is that if we choose a
negative value for VD you can make this
exponential term almost vanish by
reverse biasing
your basically
pin diode and make your total current
uh be completely dominated by the photo
current and that makes a very good you
know uh photo detector so here's
graphically uh how the IV
characteristics of the device uh work so
you have mult we have multiple curves
here each of these blue curves is for a
different value of incident Optical
power on the device so the for the this
this top one is where there's no Optical
incident power you get your IV curve and
then as you increase your Photon flux
you get different curves now it's broken
into three regions there's the forward
bias or the photovoltaic regime and
that's where your VD the you know the
bias voltage of the device is positive
and you get this exponential Behavior
right those that's where you the
exponential term dominates and it's it's
extremely difficult to do sensing in
this region because again your behavior
is what if what we sense out of the
device is this current and it's
dominated by this exponential behavior
in the forward bias regime but if you
look at the reverse bias or the
photoconductive regime the exponential
term basically becomes negligible and
something very interesting happens the
the actual current that you get out of
the device it's almost
with incident Photon flux so it's
basically a perfect linear sensor and in
that regime and that's why you want to
apply a reverse bias voltage
however if if you make your bias voltage
too negative and hit the the so-called
breakdown voltage of the device you can
suddenly get a giant you know in rush in
Rush of current that that makes it again
non-linear so so this is essentially the
most linear part uh and and then in the
so-called Geiger regime
um you can get non-linear Behavior out
of the out of the device I think that's
a good place to stop we'll we'll
continue the discussion uh next time any
questions
okay see you next time